the elephant trap starts out with the D4
D5 C4 the Queen's Gambit line E6 I'm
gonna decline that line Knight to C3
Knight F6 and then Bishop two G5 pinning
down the Knight two this queen here
Knight to D7 as a continuation defending
this and then after the pawn takes which
is fairly common from White the pawn can
recapture now white may have a sense
that he can just come in and take this
Pawn since the knights blocking this
queen here he may say yeah he can't
recapture with his Knight that Bishop is
pinning down the Knight to the queen
that's exactly what we want white to
think because after he takes here on D5
black can take the Knight doesn't even
matter that the queen is exposed here if
the bishop comes down and takes here on
d8 that's going to be completely fine